Je suis content que tu sois venu et l'hiver on peut
devenir un peu morne et
bien seul bien mr.  Les visites de Rochester sont toujours
inattendues premier mr.  Rochester pourquoi ils
étaient de thornfield êtes-vous blessé monsieur
connaisseur parlez-moi quelle est votre histoire
de mur j'ai été élevé seul j'ai
ensuite fréquenté l'école où j'ai reçu la
meilleure éducation possible
quelle sorte d'homme est-il
il est bon  maître pensez-vous que ma
belle beauté est de peu d'importance
ne rougissez pas
vous portez une chose r3 je dois vous avoir pour
ma maison voici le petit connaisseur
de la méthamphétamine gardez-le à distance
mademoiselle ingram vient elle est une grande faveur
pour cette
[musique]
nous '  Je flotte doucement dans le courant de la
vie, ignorant les rochers qui attendent
pour te tester, penses-tu que
parce que je suis un pauvre petit obscur
le temps sans âme et sans cœur
[Musique]
toi